je suis ravie d'accueillir aujourd'hui
Monsieur Eric Dupont-Moretti garde des
sceaux la délégation au droit des
enfants a souhaité vous auditionner afin
que vous nous présentiez les initiatives
de votre ministère pour améliorer la
protection des enfants mais surtout pour
voir comment la parole de l'enfant peut
être mieux prise en compte au niveau de
la justice vous avez effectué récemment
plusieurs annonces en septembre dernier
vous avez annoncé une modification
législative qui permettrait de retrait
de principe de l'autorité parentale en
cas de condamnation d'un parent pour
violence sexuelle incestueuse sur son
enfant lors du dernier comité
interministériel consacré l'enfant sa
première ministre a de nouveau présenté
dispositifs par ailleurs la civisme que
nous avons additionné la semaine
dernière la légalement pour un tel
dispositif pouvez-vous nous en dire plus
sur son calendrier de mise en oeuvre au
sein de cette délégation nous sommes
plusieurs à nous interroger également
sur une suspension immédiate de
l'autorité parentale et de
l'autorisation de garde en cas de dépôt
de plainte pour des violences sexuelles
sur l'enfant certains souhaiteraient
même un retrait de l'autorité parentale
en cas de violence conjugale pour le les
parents auteurs j'aimerais vous entendre
sur ces sujets qui sont à notre
réflexion
lors de votre audition après auprès de
la commission des lois vous avez
également indiqué la mise en place d'un
accompagnement de l'enfant par des
associations d'aide aux victimes tout au
long du processus pénal et
l'intervention d'un administrateur
Haddock en cas de défaillance parentale
ces administrateurs Haddock seront-ils
nommés dès qu'un parent et défaillants
et dès le début de la procédure comment
seront-ils défrayés et qu'en pensez-vous
mettre en place ce dispositif sur ce
point de mieux accompagner l'enfant je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur le
dispositif des chiens d'assistant
judiciaire que j'ai pu voir à l'oeuvre
il semblerait qu'une réflexion soit en
cours au sein de votre ministère pour
savoir où prendre ses chiens qui doit
les gérer pour ma part j'ai vu ces
chiens évoluer dans divers
environnements et par divers porteurs
et j'ai pu voir le bienfait de ces
chiens auprès des enfants
je pense que les chiens doivent
continuer à être dressés par handiciens
et être de préférence placée auprès des
associations de victimes car cela permet
d'avoir ces chiens dans toutes les
situations de la prise en compte de la
parole de l'enfant de l'audition y
compris à l'hôpital jusqu'au jugement
j'aimerais donc vous entendre sur ce
sujet là monsieur le garde des sceaux
concernant la protection de l'enfance
vous le savez je plaide pour que la
justice en matière d'assistance
éducative soit plus en conformité avec
les autres pans de la justice
pour ma part je pense qu'un avocat
devrait être désigné de manière
obligatoire dès qu'un placement est
envisagé il devrait être possible
également de faire appel des enquêtes
sociales et toujours concernant la prise
en compte de la parole de l'enfant il
faudrait lui demander son autorisation
d'être remis en présence de son parent
maltraitance pouvez-vous nous indiquer
votre point de vue sur ces sujets et ce
qui est envisagé pour améliorer la
situation
toujours concernant le requête de la
parole de l'enfant le gouvernement
déploie les yeux à peine dans tous les
départements afin de permettre de
recueillir la parole dans des conditions
optimales avec des professionnels formés
au protocole niche et en vidéo c'est une
très bonne chose toutefois les
enquêteurs passent ensuite des heures à
retranscrire à l'écrit les propos et les
attitudes des enfants ne serait-il pas
plus simple d'arrêter ses
retranscriptions et de demander au juges
plutôt de regarder ces auditions qui
permettrait qui plus est qu'il se fasse
leur intime conviction
j'ai également pu voir lors de mes
déplacements
le dispositif de confrontation en visio
d'un enfant de à son agresseur à partir
d'une de ses salles du à peine il était
accompagné d'un enquêteur et d'un avocat
à votre avis est-ce qu'on pourrait
envisager ce type de procédure en visio
pour les auditions des parquets voir aux
témoignages lors des procès cela serait
moins intimidant pour les enfants
enfin j'ai rencontré des professionnels
toujours de ses yeux à peine ils ont vu
certains de l'air préconisations non
entendues par les procureurs et les
juges et dépité et sachant qu'il
redonnait des enfants à leurs agresseurs
ils ont été tout retournés
comment peut-on agir monsieur le
ministre pour fluidifier les échanges
entre le médical et la justice
pourrait-on envisager en cas de doute
d'hospitalisation l'hospitalisé l'enfant
quelques jours comme pour le protocole
féminicide le temps d'y voir plus clair
enfin comment peut-on protéger la parole
des médecins pour éviter qu'ils se
retrouvent jugé pour émission dans la
vie privée des familles alors qu'ils
n'ont voulu faire que leurs devoirs de
signalement
et enfin pour finir monsieur le ministre
la délégation va mettre en place à
partir du mois de janvier un groupe de
travail sur la prise en charge des
enfants de retour de la zone Irako
syrienne la France a été condamnée par
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
en septembre dernier au motif que les
décisions du gouvernement puissent être
contrôlés afin d'éviter tout risque
d'arbitraire le rejet d'une demande de
retour soit territoire national doit
pouvoir faire l'objet d'un examen
individuel approprié par un organe
indépendant chargé d'en contrôler
l'égalité voilà les propos de la
commission
pouvez-vous nous indiquer du coup quel
protocole va être retenu pour répondre à
cette demande de la CEDH voilà Monsieur
le Ministre quelques-unes des questions
je vous laisse bien entendu la parole et
après nous la donnerons à un orateur par
groupe dans un premier temps et en
fonction du temps restant nous verrons
pour les autres collègues je vous
remercie et je vous laisse la parole
monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente chère Perrine
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
suis je suis très heureux de venir pour
la première fois dans les délégations
endroit des enfants de l'Assemblée
nationale
d'abord je veux saluer la création de
votre délégation
qui est de mon point de vue un
formidable outil pour faire avancer les
choses
et pour faire avancer en particulier la
cause de la protection de l'enfance
c'est l'aboutissement d'un engagement
total de nombreux députés dans la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
vous me l'avez la présidence de notre
ami
Erwan et de tant d'autres
l'enfant se le savez a été placé par le
Président de la République
comme l'une des priorités de ce nouveau
quinquennat et la prise en compte du
droit des enfants se situe au cœur de la
feuille de route du gouvernement
bien sûr ministère de la Justice
participe à la défense et à la promotion
des droits des enfants
la justice des mineurs s'exerce au
quotidien sur l'ensemble du territoire
tente en matière de protection de
l'enfance que de prévention de la
délinquance
et il est aujourd'hui absolument
primordial de réaffirmer la spécificité
et l'importance d'une justice des
mineurs qui soient bien sûr une justice
de qualité
pour lui permettre de mener l'ensemble
de ces de ces missions le ministère de
la Justice bénéficiera je veux le
rappeler rapidement grâce à vous
l'année prochaine d'une nouvelle hausse
de ne plus de 8% pour la troisième année
consécutive et ce budget 2023 permettra
notamment de donner à la justice des
mineurs des moyens à la hauteur de sa
mission et des moyens pour son avenir en
valorisant les compétences et l'action
de chacun des professionnels du monde
judiciaire vous le savez 1500 magistrats
1500 greffiers seront recrutés sur le
quinquennat
soit en 5 ans plus que durant les 20
dernières années
les chantiers actuels du ministère de la
justice en matière de justice des
mineurs sont évidemment nombreux tant en
matière pénale avec la première année de
mise en oeuvre du code de justice pénale
des mineurs qu'en est-il pour la
protection des enfants
matière pénale d'abord puisque nous
avons fêté le 30 septembre au dernier le
premier anniversaire de l'entrée en
vigueur du CJPM
vous le savez ce code modifie en
profondeur la procédure pénale
applicable mineur et un an après son
entrée en vigueur plusieurs de ses
objectifs sont déjà atteints avec des
résultats que l'on peut qualifier de
probant
les délais du jugement sont passés du
double au simple
9,1 - sur le plan national contre plus
de 18 mois autrefois
le nombre de mineurs incarcérés à
diminué et parmi les mineurs incarcérés
la part de ceux placer en détention
provisoire apparaît nettement tombé et
je veux ici saluer l'engagement de tous
les magistrats greffiers éducateur PJJ
dans la mise en œuvre de cette réforme
indispensable
cette justice plus rapide
permet également aux victimes d'être
mieux entendu mieux considérer et ça
n'est pas à vous bien sûr que je veux
dire que c'est l'un un point qui est
primordial je reviendrai prochainement
devant le Parlement pour dresser un
bilan plus exhaustif de la réforme
de la justice pénale des mineurs en lien
avec la mission d'évaluation qui est en
cours et qui est piloté par vos
collègues Jean terrier et Cécile Hunter
Mayer
me dire civile je veux saluer la
promulgation de la loi du 7 février 2022
relative à la protection des enfants
dont votre collègue Michel perron était
le rapporteur
et cette loi
est venue compléter les mesures de la
stratégie nationale de prévention et de
protection de l'enfance
comme vous le savez elle améliore la
prise en charge des mineurs non
accompagnés et renforce l'accompagnement
des jeunes majeurs et désormais un
avocat est présent auprès du mineur à
chaque fois que son intérêt le réclame
un pilotage clair de la politique
publique de la protection de l'enfance
est évidemment très attendu par nos
concitoyens pour mieux protéger les
enfants il est absolument indispensable
que les départements dont c'est la
compétence première
dialogue de façon plus étroite avec
l'institution judiciaire et j'ai
d'ailleurs reçu récemment le président
Sauvadet dans le cadre d'un dialogue que
je peux qualifier très constructif avec
les départements de France en matière de
protection de l'enfance
la place de la justice est évidemment
essentielle le travail des 522 juges des
enfants sur ces questions de protection
de l'enfance se fait bien sûr avec tous
les acteurs publics et ne les oublions
pas les acteurs du monde associatif
un comité interministériel de l'enfant
s'est réuni pour la première fois le 21
novembre dernier à l'Hôtel Matignon
trois objectifs principaux lutter contre
les violences faites aux enfants
garantir l'égalité des chances aux
enfants et aux jeunes
et
agir pour le développement et l'avenir
de tous les enfants on impliquant
plusieurs ministères santé éducation
nationale intérieure collectivités
territoriale et bien sûr le ministère de
la Justice
ensuite en fin de rapport de renforcer
l'action pénale et judiciaire pour les
auteurs de violences faites aux enfants
les premières préconisations de la
commission indépendante sur l'inceste et
les violences sexuelles la civisme sont
actuellement expertisées nous y
reviendrons afin d'apporter des
solutions concrètes le plus rapidement
possible
d'ici la fin du mois je prendrai une
circulaire cet effet
circulaire spécifiquement dédié à la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
enfants et ayant vocation à faire de
cette lutte un enjeu prioritaire d'une
envergure similaire à celle que nous
conduisons déjà contre les violences
conjugales
afin de lutter contre la prostitution
des mineurs des actions en vue
d'améliorer le repérage de ces
situations de lutter contre les réseaux
seront menées en lien avec les services
du ministère de l'Intérieur le ministère
de la Justice s'investit également dans
des actions relatives à la garantie de
l'insertion professionnelle et sociale
des enfants les plus fragiles en
construisant des partenariats rénovés
avec les armées nous y reviendrons si
vous le voulez avec les entreprises pour
qu'aucun enfant ne soit laissé sur le
bord du chemin l'insertion étant bien
évidemment
l'une des clés pour préserver
notamment la cohésion de notre de notre
pays le ministère de la Justice est
encore moteur aux côtés d'autres
ministères sur les réflexions autour de
la protection des enfants dans le champ
numérique au niveau national et
international et notamment en matière de
contenu à caractère pornographique
mieux protéger les enfants c'est
également les empêcher d'avoir accès à
des visuels trop violents
inadapté pour leur âge et leur maturité
dont je pense qu'ils sont
générateurs d'une grande violence et
donc d'une montée en puissance d'un
certain type de
délinquance ce travail il est porté en
interministériel sous l'égide du
Ministère de la Culture et avec l'arcome
qui est comme vous le savez l'Autorité
de régulation de la communication
audiovisuelle et numérique
au niveau européen
des travaux sont en cours dans le cadre
de la prévention et de la lutte contre
les abus sexuels sur les mineurs
un règlement dit à SM c'est la chronyme
française ou
CSA c'est l'acronyme anglais
chill de sexuel à BIOS est en
préparation le texte européen est suivi
à titre principal par l'intérieur mais
également avec beaucoup d'attention par
le ministère de la Justice sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs qui concerne la lutte contre
la pédopornographie en ligne la
Commission européenne propose d'une part
la création d'un centre européen de
prévention et de lutte contre les abus
sexuels sur mineurs et d'autre part de
renforcer la réglementation visant à
lutter contre la pédo pornographie en
ligne ce texte vise en particulier à
renforcer les obligations
général pesant sur les fournisseurs de
services en ligne et ils prévoient
également des obligations plus ciblées
de signalement de détection de retrait
de blocage et d'identification des
contenus sous la responsabilité
d'autorité nationale de coordination
farose fonctionne bien nous souhaitons
évidemment conserver cet outil nous
souhaitons
l'amplifier mieux protéger les enfants
c'est bien sûr mieux les prendre en
charge quand ils sont victimes et c'est
pourquoi nous développons actuellement
un dispositif de meilleure
accompagnement pour les enfants tout au
long du processus pénal avec
d'abord un passage à l'uaped nous en
avons actuellement 75
bientôt courant 2023 et plus tard en
2024 chaque département sera doté d'une
telle structure
que comme vous madame la Présidente je
suis allé visiter
expertisé et le travail
qui se fait là est un travail
d'excellence c'est une prise en charge
pluridisciplinaire sanitaire parfois
médical médico-légal psychologique
psychiatrique sociale judiciaire bien
sûr et on évoquera cette question de la
retranscription des des procès-verbaux
la difficulté de ne pas retranscrire
c'est comment communique-t-on aux autres
parties ce document
comment
s'exerce le contradictoire
ce sont des questions procédures qui
sont importantes si tout le monde à la
même chose on peut commencer à discuter
on y travaille on y réfléchit
ensuite il y a les associations d'aide
aux victimes qui seront spécialisées
pour intervenir aux côtés des mineurs
par essentiel on a beaucoup parlé de
spécialisation des juridictions ce qui
concerne les violences faites aux femmes
vous le savez
tout ce qui est spécialisation mais on
peut mettre beaucoup de choses dans ce
mot spécialisation mais en tous les cas
davantage de formation un accompagnement
particulier pour les enfants c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument utile
les administrateurs adoptent je souhaite
évidemment les développer je voudrais
d'ailleurs vous dire à ce propos que
administrateur Adobe pour les gamins
c'est pas un très joli mot ça veut pas
dire grand chose
j'ai pensé mais je vous soumets cela on
lance un petit concours aujourd'hui
parce qu'on est aussi dans de la
co-construction à part un judiciaire
c'est plus entendable pour un petit
maintenant si vous avez une autre
proposition à faire je suis preneur mais
c'est vrai que dire à un gamin de 6 ans
tu vas rencontrer ton administrateur
Adobe voilà c'est un détail mais les
détails sont importants
le chien d'assistance judiciaire bon
alors
c'est une vieille idée
qui nous vient de Cahors d'abord
pourquoi Cahors parce que l'un des
magistrats du parc et Cahors souhaité
développer
cette idée que au fond la présence du
chien ne permettait à l'enfant
d'appréhender moins mal le procès qui
s'ouvre c'est l'histoire du doudou d'une
certaine façon en caresse le chien on se
réfugie auprès de l'animal bon
quand je suis allé à l'UAPE j'ai eu la
possibilité de voir des choses
qui démontent que l'enfant évidemment
est parfois dans le dans le silence
parce qu'il est plus confortable que les
mots et parfois ce qu'il donne à voir de
son corps évidemment montre à quel point
on est dans le traumatisme
et le chien permet pour partie de se
libérer de ça mais
je vais d'abord souligner le
l'engagement du get tienien qui était
très impliqué sur cette question mais
nous y travaillons depuis longtemps
parce que il y a la question du dressage
des chiens
s'agit pas d'aller en chercher
et puis de les de les confier quelques
instants des gamins faut pas qu'ils
aboient pendant les interrogatoires par
exemple mais c'est pas rien c'est des
petits détails et sont des détails qui
ont d'un coup et notamment le coût du
dressage bon alors on a beaucoup
réfléchi à ces questions combien de
temps il faudrait c'est un chien
d'aveugle c'est plus de 2 ans
on n'a pas besoin de cette d'un dressage
poussé à ce point
il faut que le chien soit calme qu'il
réponde à un certain nombre d'ordre qui
soit pas timides qui soit gentil voilà
certains nombre de choses donc on est en
train de réfléchir et
je dois dire que ça avance vite je ferai
très prochainement des annonces d'idées
elle est très claire je souhaite et je
vous l'annonce un déploiement beaucoup
plus large de ce dispositif bon la
chaleur et le réconfort de de l'animal
apporte aux victimes beaucoup de
beaucoup de calme et beaucoup de
tranquillité et ça permet aux petits de
revenir plus facilement sur les faits
qu'ils ont subi c'est un outil de plus
au service des victimes bien sûr des
mineurs et je souhaite mettre à la
disposition des juridictions
ce dispositif il y a aujourd'hui pour
que vous sachiez déjà 10 chiens sur le
territoire mais on a 164 TJ donc il faut
le multiplier le développer et je
travaille en particulier avec
espérance sur sur ces questions là
il faut que la justice rassure l'enfant
je vais présenter là aussi prochainement
un dispositif d'accompagnement du mineur
victime tout au long du processus pénal
bon
s'agissant des yeux à peine d'abord
les unités situe au sein même des
hôpitaux
sont évidemment spécialisés
spécialement équipée le matériel de
soins bon tout ça vous le savez
santé traumatisme constatation médicale
j'ai déjà dit du matériel
d'enregistrement audiovisuel pour capter
la parole du mineur pour capter aussi
l'image du mineur dans sa difficulté à
exprimer les choses et naturellement les
silences sont parfois très éloquents
l'enregistrés encore une fois pour les
fins de l'enquête et ce sont évidemment
des professionnels du judiciaire et de
la santé de la protection de l'enfance
qui se déplace et ça c'est un des
intérêts l'uaped au chevet si j'ose dire
de du mineur victime la question des
sanctions pénales contre les auteurs de
violences faites aux enfants et
évidemment une question tout à fait
primordiale oui d'ailleurs dire que dans
les yeux à peine il y a déjà parfois des
chiens
d'assistant judiciaire et dans les
juridictions en face de jugement ça fait
partie
de quelque chose que l'on a que l'on
appelle l'accompagnement évidemment
puisque lui appel c'est tout au début
que les choses se passent et puis
ensuite s'il y a un procès en étant en
phase d'une certaine façon terminale de
la procédure finale bien sûr et les
chiens on les retrouve on les retrouvera
quand tout ça sera généralisé du début à
la fin
sur les questions de sanction pénales
contre les auteurs de violence faite aux
enfants évidemment une question
primordiale et je souhaite que le juge
pénal statut de manière systématique
je veux insister sur ce point
sur le maintien de l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale quand c'est un
parent qui agresse son enfant
et s'agissant de la suspension de cette
autorité parentale avant une
condamnation moi je dis qu'il faut être
extrêmement prudent
il faut être prudent
parce que d'abord il y a des risques
constitutionnels tout simplement et nous
sommes tenus évidemment par les règles
constitutionnelles qui ne sont pas à nos
yeux des règles superfétatoires et aussi
des risques disons le
d'instrumentalisation
les juridictions savent la mémoire des
juridictions C il y a parfois des
risques d'instrumentalisation
j'ai donc favorable à ce qu'une telle
suspension intervienne en code poursuite
par le procureur de la République en
lien avec le juge aux affaires
familiales et cette évolution
nécessitera un vecteur législatif et je
serai ravi de travailler avec votre
délégation madame la Présidente pour la
faire aboutir cette idée mais il faut
que nous respections évidemment les
règles et que nous ayons une certaine
prudence protéger les enfants c'est
aussi bien sûr leur permettre de
connaître leurs droits afin qu'ils
puissent savoir comment les actionner et
là encore les présidents de tribunaux
judiciaires président des conseils
départementaux de l'accès au droit même
des actions concrètes de promotion des
droits pour les mineurs des points
d'accès au droit sont ouverts
dans les établissements pénitentiaires
pour mineurs et je vous annonce qu'ils
vont être généralisés
les éducateurs de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse
anime bien évidemment des formations des
ateliers dans les établissements
scolaires pour présenter l'organisation
de la justice en France pour
sensibiliser les jeunes sur leurs droits
mais aussi bien sûr sur leurs devoirs
bien connaître
les règles les défendre et je veux ici
saluer l'engagement des des éducs
comme disent
beaucoup de jeunes pour ne pas dire tous
ils sont pour moi des seins des saints
civils parce qu'il faut y croire il faut
y croire et je voudrais rendre hommage
particulier à l'un d'entre eux qui il y
a une bonne dizaine de jours a été
agressé au sein d'un centre éducatif
fermé des gens pénétré dans le centre
éducatif fermé armé il voulait en
découdre avec des jeunes qui étaient
dans le CF et au péril de son intégrité
physique l'éducateur s'y est opposé
il n'y a pas eu de
violences physiques proprement parler
mais il a vécu un très sale moment
ouais
et quand j'ai appelé cet homme
pour lui dire mon soutien d'effectif
il ne me parlait que des enfants
je voudrais aborder une dernière
question on aime la présidente qui porte
sur les suites de l'arrêt de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
concernant le retour des familles de
combattants terroristes retenus en Syrie
sans
m'étendre sur ces mesures parce que je
vais les annoncer
on est allé chercher à l'étranger
un dispositif que je veux étendre
et qui conduit les petits enfants qui
vont témoigner à se familiariser avec
la salle d'audience dans laquelle ils
vont devoir témoigner
c'est quelque chose de très important
parce que évidemment ces enfants
appréhendent ce qui est pour eux une
véritable épreuve
donc il faut qu'il soit accompagné bien
accompagner pour regarder la salle
l'appréhender monter sur le bureau du
président pardon de le dire ainsi ou du
procureur
ce familiariser avec cet endroit
donc je j'aurai l'occasion dans les
jours qui viennent de préciser tout ça
parce que nous avons
mis en place
nous sommes en train de
d'y réfléchir encore quelques instants
mais il y aura quelque chose de cet
ordre pour aider les
les plus petits en particulier mais je
pense que tout le monde appréhende de
témoigner devant une juridiction quand
il est victime mais même les adultes
mais pour les enfants je pense qu'on
peut les aider de cette de cette façon
alors revenons-en si vous le voulez bien
est-ce que vous m'avez posé la question
à l'arrêt de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme qui concerne les
retours de famille de combattants
terroristes qui sont retenus en Syrie
la Cour aurait édité n'a condamné la
France que pour le manque de
formalisation du processus
décisionnel conduisante au nom
rapatriement
n'avons pas été condamné parce que nous
n'avons pas rapatriés
et comme le gouvernement le soutenait la
Cour a considéré et c'est extrêmement
important parce que j'entends et je lis
beaucoup de choses de beaucoup de Yaka
faucon
la Cour a considéré que la France ne
peut pas être tenu pour responsable des
conditions de vie dans les camps du
nord-est de la Syrie pour une raison
simple c'est qu'elle n'y exerce pas sa
juridiction et c'est mesdames et
messieurs les députés la stricte réalité
j'ajoute que ces questions très
complexes il y a une question majeure
qui est la sécurité
de ce
qui serait chargé ou qui sont chargés ou
qui ont été chargés de récupérer les
femmes qui sont systématiquement
judiciarisés et les enfants qui eux
naturellement nous en sommes tous
convaincus ne sont coupables de rien
la Cour a aussi confirmé que les
engagements internationaux de la France
en matière de protection des droits de
l'homme
n'impose pas à la France de rapatrier
les personnes retenues dans le nord-est
syrien
nous l'avons fait et nous le faisons et
nous le ferons chaque fois que c'est
possible
et conformément à l'arrêt de la Cour les
demandes ont donc été réexaminées et une
réponse motivée a été envoyé requérantes
et ce sera désormais la procédure de
droite commun et c'est demande pourront
faire l'objet de recours devant le juge
administratif ce qui d'ailleurs a été
précisé dans les réponses que nous avons
adressées la France je le dis c'est
d'ores et déjà mise en conformité avec
l'arrêt de la cour
alors entre
une réflexion mesurée
équilibrée et surtout pragmatique et
puis le Yaka faucon que certains
expriment avec une désinvolture et une
aisance
qui permet à cela qui s'exprime
d'oublier notamment les questions de
sécurité
il y a vous l'avez bien compris de
véritables différences et moi il me
semble
utile de rappeler ces choses parce que
j'ai lu tellement de choses et que
notamment nous abandonnions les enfants
je pense qu'on est assez loin de la
réalité je ferme la parenthèse et nous y
reviendrons si vous le souhaitez pour
conclure
je veux terminer par bref point sur sur
ces mineurs qui sont rentrés de Syrie
bon cette situation allait vous
l'imaginez
particulièrement complexe elle mérite
évidemment toute notre attention
notre politique et les articulée autour
de beaucoup d'humanité mais aussi bien
sûr d'une vigilance absolue
humanité ils sont pas responsables ces
gamins bien sûr des choix qui ont été
faits
par leurs parents et on peut même dire
des choix criminels qui ont été faits
par leurs parents
et vigilance absolue parce que
ce sont selon une formule qui est
désormais consacrée les lions saut du
califat
comment on règle tout ça
c'est difficile
vous avez sans doute entendu un certain
nombre de pédopsychiatre s'exprimer sur
ces questions et elles sont loin d'être
simples
notre crème bien sûr c'est que ces
enfants en grandissant soient
ultérieurement récupérés par des groupes
terroristes on ne peut pas ne pas
envisager cela
ils sont au nombre de 270
126 filles 144 garçons
71% ont moins de 10 ans
119 enfants soit 44% sont nés en zone
Irako syrienne sans état civil
et sans filiation
et ses enfants sont désormais répartis
sur le territoire national en fonction
des lieux où ils peuvent avoir des
attaches familiales naturellement des
attaches familiales
n'ayant pas choisi bien sûr
ce que les parents
ont envisagé en partant nous faire la
guerre pour être
pour être bref
c'est ces enfants ils font
systématiquement systématiquement
l'objet pardon d'une double prise en
charge
conformément à une instruction
interministérielle du 21 avril
que j'ai complété par une circulaire à
mes services du 18 octobre dernier
j'insiste sur un point ils sont
systématiquement suivis à leur arrivée
dans le cadre de procédures d'assistance
éducative
éventuellement cumuler avec des
placements en famille quand c'est
possible ou en structure éducative et ce
suivi judiciaire se double d'un suivi
administratif au sein des cellules de
prévention de la radicalisation et
d'accompagnement des familles ce qui
implique l'ensemble des acteurs locaux
en contact avec ses enfants sous la
coordination générale du parquet
national antiterroriste humanité vous
disait et vigilance absolue voilà les
deux axes de notre politique pour faire
face à des situations au combien
complexes pour suivre et accompagner ses
enfants je tiens à vous faire part de ma
totale détermination
dans la défense du droit des enfants
ainsi que l'engagement des
professionnels de justice qu'elle soit
pénale ou civiles pour les protéger le
mieux possible et maintenant madame la
Présidente je répondrai avec grand
plaisir à toutes les questions que vous
voudrez bien me poser
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux pour
cet entretien cette ces propos
liminaires pardon et bien entendu tiens
à vous assurer de notre envie de notre
attente et de notre enthousiasme à
travailler avec vous sur les sujets que
nous avons évoqués mais dans l'état
actuel je vais laisser la parole à un
orateur de chaque groupe politique et je
reviendrai à la fin si les réponses pour
moi n'ont pas été apportées sur certains
points qui méritent d'être complété je
pense je vais laisser pour le groupe
Renaissance Philippe Dunoyer
c'est deux minutes chers collègues pour
que le garde des sceaux et le temps de
nous répondre
tenir en 2019 merci beaucoup monsieur le
garde des sous merci pour votre présence
le soutien également à la délégation qui
est une nouveauté à laquelle nous
croyons beaucoup vous dire simplement
que je le remercie encore la délégation
a choisi comme premier rapport
d'information une mission sur
l'évaluation des violences commises sur
mineur en outre-mer je suis moi-même
comme vous le savez député de nouvelles
Calédonie c'est sur ce champ là que je
vais limiter mon intervention même la
président parce que malheureusement en
outre-mer et en Nouvelle-Calédonie
singulièrement il existe un taux de
violence intrafamiliale qui est record à
l'échelle de
notre pays
nous cherchons aussi potentiellement à
démontrer le lien évident entre les
violences intrafamilales et les
violences commises sur mineur
malheureusement probablement encore
assez méconnu sur nos territoires et
l'État je dois le dire a fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour lutter contre ces
violences intrafamiliales des moyens
humains matériels financiers ont été
déployés
mais il demeure quand même un outil dont
une partie a été évoquée par par vous
même tout à l'heure dans votre
intervention avec les unités d'accueil
pédiatrique d'enfants sans danger mais
plus globalement un service d'unité
médico-judiciaire qui nous manque qui
fait défaut en Nouvelle-Calédonie alors
c'est essentiellement dû à la
conjonction de des compétences et de la
répartition des compétences entre un
territoire qui est compétent en matière
de santé et l'État qui est en matière de
justice mais je voulais signaler
l'importance extrême que nous soyons
dotés de cette unité c'est bien sûr à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie également d'être
partenaire de cette opération et un
prochain contrat développement pourrait
en être un des supports mais ce que je
voudrais simplement voilà si vous
demandez si vous êtes en accord et au
soutien bien sûr de l'accompagnement de
cette prochaine unité médico-judiciaire
en Nouvelle-Calédonie merci
le président en général on fait passer
tous les orateurs de groupe mais c'est
si ça vous convient si vous voulez
répondre après chaque on peut aussi
c'est à votre convenance
à la fin on allez-y la réponse était
brève c'était un adverbe totalement
totalement ton soutien bien sûr donc je
me suis dit comme c'était court et puis
vous attendiez cette réponse
légitimement parce que effectivement il
y a pas du MJ
la direction des affaires civiles et des
grâces a été saisie d'une demande qui
émane des chefs de cours
les frais aujourd'hui médico-légos sont
considéré comme des fois de justice Vous
savez certaines façons pour pallier
à l'absence l'absence pardonnez-moi du
MJ mais je suis tout à fait valable à ce
que l'on examine ça avec beaucoup de
intérêt parce que effectivement c'est
utile et vous déplorez juste titre
l'absence du MG donc la réponse est
oui totalement ton soutien
si beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour le
groupe principal madame Caroline
Parmentier merci madame la présidente
monsieur le garde des sceaux aujourd'hui
il n'a jamais été aussi facile pour les
mineurs pour des enfants d'accéder à des
contenus pornographiques de manière
délibérée ou accidentelle à des contenus
de plus en plus violents et toxiques
pour eux en octobre dernier le rapport
d'information sénatoriale porno l'enfer
du décor alerté deux tiers des enfants
de moins de 15 ans et un tiers de ceux
de moins de 12 ans ont déjà été exposés
à des images pornographiques on sait que
les images véhiculées par la
pornographie traumatisent et affecte
durablement et profondément de nombreux
jeunes dans la construction de leur
personnalité il contribue également à la
banalisation des actes de violence
sexuelle et des actes de violence contre
les femmes il y a déjà eu plusieurs
demandes faites par des parlementaires
aux sensibilités politiques différentes
mais nous n'avons pas suffisamment
progresser sur cette question je viens
de déposer une proposition de résolution
que je tiens ici à votre disposition
demandant une commission d'enquête les
pistes sont nombreuses travail de
communication vis-à-vis des parents
vis-à-vis des mineurs qui souffrent
d'addiction loin de tout jugement moral
sanctions financière infligées aux
fournir sur d'accès Internet qui ne
mettraient pas en place des systèmes de
contrôle d'âge la CNIL par exemple
recommande que l'internaute fournisse un
justificatif pour prouver son âge dans
l'attente de la vallée la validation de
ce justificatif le site ne devrait plus
laisser apparaître aucune image
pornographique et devrait afficher un
écran noir cette mesure paraît facile à
mettre en oeuvre monsieur le ministre
comment entendez-vous renforcer le
contrôle de l'âge dans l'accès au site
pornographique et plus généralement que
comptez-vous faire pour protéger les
mineurs contre la pornographie je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup pour le groupe LFI madame
Maximy merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre vous avez déclaré
au sujet de la protection de l'enfance
c'est un sujet de névralgique pour moi
effectivement vous n'êtes parler
d'endommage aux éducateurs moi je vais
vous parler des alertes qui sont
nombreuses dans ce domaine nombreuses et
récurrentes et qui d'ailleurs s'accélère
et s'amplifie ces alertes viennent des
professionnels des éducateurs de la
social à l'enfance mais aussi des juges
notamment des juges pour enfants
récemment la Défenseur des droits s'est
saisi sur la situation de deux
départements en France ce qui est
évidemment très préoccupant elle
considère que la protection de l'enfance
est totalement dégradée qu'il y a un
risque pour le respect de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant
elle parle de ces deux départements mais
elle souligne d'ailleurs dans sa césine
que la protection de l'enfance dans de
nombreux territoires n'est plus du ment
assuré alors il y a des chiffres qui ont
été qui sont sortis il y a quelques mois
suite à un travail de recherche
journalistique réalisé par un
journaliste de Médiapart et qui a listé
quelques placements mesures mon exécuté
à Nancy nous avions à ce moment-là 32
placements non exécutés certains
d'ailleurs qui dataient depuis 4 mois en
Loire-Atlantique c'est 100 placements
non exécutés dans le Maine-et-Loire en
mai dernier c'était 160 placements non
exécutés les tribunal estimés qu'il
fallait six mois un an pour obtenir une
place à Châteauroux à d'autres villes
c'est entre 6 mois et un an pour accéder
à une mesure de la MO en
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est 11 mois
d'attente pour exécuter des mesures et
deux ans pour une AEMO renforcée à
Saint-Nazaire c'est 200 mesures d'avion
qui ne sont pas exécutés donc ces
chiffres je les dis c'est le travail
journalistique parce qu'en fait il n'y a
pas de chiffres officiels il n'y a pas
de comptage de travail de mesure
d'évaluation aujourd'hui de cette
situation
euh donc il est difficile en fait
d'avoir une vision d'ensemble de de la
situation de notre pays en termes de
protection de l'enfance et pourtant
quand on s'y intéresse on se rend compte
que c'est un problème qui est structurel
que nous retrouvons dans tous les
départements aujourd'hui du fait d'un
effondrement de la politique de la
protection de l'enfant un effondrement
au niveau de l'accès au droit et surtout
des places et des moyens disponibles
pour les éducateurs vous avez rendu à
moi aux éducateurs et aujourd'hui ils
alertent de la souffrance des dents
enfin des difficultés qu'ils ont à
exposer à faire leur métier alors moi je
voulais juste vous demander quel était
votre feuille de route justement pour
pouvoir agir vraiment structurellement
sur la non exécution des mesures et des
placements notamment avant d'éviter
enfin d'éviter parce que nous le savons
des drames vont avoir lieu ont déjà eu
lieu et vont avoir lieu de manière
encore plus importante merci Madame
Maxime et pour le groupe des
Républicains monsieur Fortier
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je souhaitais vous interroger
sur les délais de la justice familiale
les statistiques de votre ministère
indiquent pour 2020 un délai moyen de
plus de 2 ans de mois précisément pour
les procédures de rupture d'union
prononcée par le JAF le juge de faire
familial et donc un délai semblable pour
acter le lieu de résidence de l'enfant
en cas de consentement mutuel le délai
reste malheureusement important 16 mois
et n'a pas évolué depuis 2018 en cas de
recours statué sur l'autorité parentale
nécessite 13 mois supplémentaires donc
des délais qui sont conséquents c'est
délai ne sont pas dû à une augmentation
du nombre de demandes relatives aux
enfants mineurs après séparation des
enfants car celles-ci sont en baisse de
13% entre 2016 et 2020 de même pour le
nombre de recours à la justice en cas de
séparation ces délais malheureusement
vont à l'encontre de l'engagement de la
France en tant que signataire de la
Convention européenne sur l'exercice des
droits des enfants notamment à son
article 7 relatif à l'obligation d'agir
promptement ma question est très simple
et c'est la suivante comment
comptez-vous réduire les délais précité
afin que cette obligation d'agir
promptement puisse devenir une réalité
merci
merci beaucoup monsieur portier pour le
groupe démocrate monsieur banana
merci madame la Présidente
je déjà pour commencer je voulais juste
redire que que parfois notre travail
dans les délégations il porte ses fruits
on l'a vu sur la délégation du droit des
femmes et j'espère que cette délégation
que l'on crée va pouvoir justement
mettre le focus et avancer encore plus
vite sur sur la question des droits des
enfants des droits évidemment et de leur
bien-être en réalité dans cette société
assez difficile pour eux
juste quand même avant de voir tous les
points négatifs enfin parce qu'il y en a
évidemment il y a aussi des points très
positifs je voulais commencer par cela
je voulais juste rappeler quand même que
et vous l'avez fait d'ailleurs que la
justice pénale des mineurs est un est un
vrai la réforme de la justice pénale des
mineurs est un vrai succès on
on a entendu beaucoup de
beaucoup de critiques avant même qu'on
ait commencé à travailler sur le sujet
sur ce que on voulait faire et on l'a
fait et je crois qu'on l'a bien fait on
a aujourd'hui des délais qui sont
largement largement réduits
cependant évidemment la question des
enfants de leur protection il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire dans notre
pays vous le savez j'étais auteur d'un
texte sur le harcèlement scolaire et ce
texte était reposait sur trois piliers
la prévention l'accompagnement et la
protection et je crois que ces trois
piliers on peut les décliner sur tout le
travail qui nous reste à faire
vous l'avez dit la prévention vous avez
parlé des éducateurs qui font un travail
remarquable mais moi je voulais savoir
comment
comment on peut multiplier les liens
entre l'école donc l'éducation nationale
et votre
et votre ministère et le ministère de la
Justice pour que les enfants connaissent
mieux leurs droits moi j'ai la
conviction que quand les enfants
connaîtront mieux leurs droits ils
auront plus de capacité à savoir quelque
part se défendre actionner les leviers
pour se défendre
merci beaucoup monsieur balanand pour le
groupe socialiste je n'ai pas vu horizon
non plus donc pour écologie madame
Pasquier
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des sous la protection de
l'enfance vit une crise durable et
profonde le président avait déclaré
vouloir faire de la protection de
l'enfance une cause majeure de son
quinquennat si on fait des promesses
électorales en invoquant le droit des
enfants il faut se donner les moyens de
les tenir il faut donc se ressaisir
rapidement si tous les enfants méritent
que nous prenions toujours en
considération leur intérêt supérieur il
faudrait que cela soit d'autant plus le
cas pour les enfants placés et
aujourd'hui nous sommes loin du compte
quand un enfant n'a pas la chance
d'obtenir un lit dans un foyer il reste
en attente dans la famille dans le juge
a décidé de l'éloigner il est d'ailleurs
étonnant que plus de drames n'est pas eu
lieu mesure de placement en milieu
ouvert non effectués liste d'attentes
sans fin crise d'évocation Turner
surcharge des dossiers salaire moindres
le carrefour national de l'action
éducative en milieu ouvert alerté au
printemps 2022 sur le fait que 70% des
associations avaient une liste
d'attentes en 2019 elles étaient 50%.
certaines associations avaient des
listes d'attentes allant de 20 à 50
semaines au cœur de ce manque de moyens
qui est devenu un bien triste leitmotiv
se trouve l'enfant un enfant qui a déjà
beaucoup souffert en famille l'endroit
qui devrait le protéger et lui fournir
l'amour nécessaire pour grandir
intervient donc l'état qui lui aussi
comme la famille devient défaillant et
rajoute une couche de plus à la
souffrance que ses enfants ont dû sous
subir depuis le début de leur existence
palier ces listes d'attentes qui se
rallongent à ce manque de moyens
beaucoup d'établissements sociaux et
médico-sociaux doivent faire appel à des
intérimaires ou à des personnes non
qualifiées quand il n'y arrive pas c'est
une source surcharge de travail qui se
rajoute à l'équipe en place ma question
est donc la suivante comment garantir la
qualité du suivi de l'accueil et le
besoin de stabilité dans ces mineurs ont
désespérément besoin et à quelle
échéance envisagez-vous d'ouvrir les
vannes des moyens financiers pour
qu'elle puisse être assurées une
protection à la hauteur pour tous ces
enfants qui silencieusement mais
douloureusement se cachent derrière ces
statistiques
merci beaucoup nous avons fini ce
premier tour de table monsieur le
ministre d'un représentant par un groupe
poétique je vous laisse donc répondre à
ces premières questions et en fonction
du temps nous verrons ce que nous
pourrons faire après
le président
d'abord
madame la députée sur
cette question de l'accès j'allais dire
libre
à la pornographie en ligne
je crois que la seule question qui est
posée c'est mineur ou majeur
et tous les enfants qui savent lire
s'ils appuient sur le bon bouton ont
accès à la pornographie bon
vous évoquez les
les incidences sur une personnalité en
construction moi je vais plus loin je
pense que c'est générateur de
délinquance
et son des phénomènes nouveaux parfois
on parle de l'augmentation
d'adélinquance ça aille dans certains
secteurs les temps baisse dans certains
secteurs les temps hausse
et sans particuliers je pense que c'est
générateur de délinquance tout comme
d'ailleurs les contenus violents
il y a d'ailleurs
publicité là qui est très intéressante
où on voit des gamins qui évoquent les
images
moi vous avez vu ça c'est très bien fait
c'est très réaliste au fond
autre élément générateur de délinquance
à mes yeux c'est le confinement dont on
n'a pas encore mesuré les conséquences
psychologiques sur les jeunes en
particulier
donc il faut absolument qu'on lutte
contre ça j'ai
été rendu destinataire bien sûr du
rapport sur la pornographie
qui résulte du travail sénatorial
délégation
au droit des femmes et on a évidemment
évoqué toutes ces questions
et notamment le rapport à bord de la
facilité pour des enfants d'accéder à la
pornographie comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans mon discours à la fois sur
le plan national mais aussi sur le plan
européen il faut qu'on y travaille alors
vous me demandez l'écran noir je suis
pas un technicien mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que mes services
travaillent évidemment avec des
techniciens pour justement interdire
l'accès tout simplement des
l'accès de la pornographie aux mineurs
on travaille aussi sur des textes
il y a à la fois la plateforme mais il y
a aussi celui qui fait le film
et qu'il offre la plateforme qui la
diffuse
est-ce qu'on ne peut pas là
réglementer sur le plan pénal on y
réfléchit
de la même façon
sur les outils toujours sur le plan
technique mais je suis pas le mieux à
même de vous en parler parce que
évidemment il faut un certain niveau de
connaissances de ces questions
techniques mais il y a la carte
d'identité bien sûr il y a également une
carte bancaire il y a évidemment l'idée
d'associer d'ailleurs c'est le cas ça
n'est plus une idée c'était une réalité
l'arcom à la réflexion la culture
l'intérieur on est tous intéressés parce
que on constate tous dans la même chose
c'est que les mineurs ont taxé là
pornographie et on a tous la certitude
que c'était extraordinairement mauvais
mais il y a pas que le rapport le
respect que l'on doit aux femmes il y a
ça mais il n'y a pas que ça il y a aussi
j'évoquais ça avec un
justement quand on a quand j'ai reçu les
les sénatrices
à mon époque pardon
les premiers mois c'était
comment s'appelait tel Michel Mercier
alors déjà c'était révolutionnaire dans
la cour de récréation un certain d'entre
vous qui sourient
de quoi je parle
aujourd'hui on a complètement basculé
dans quelque chose d'ultra violent
moi je trouve ça très grave que des
gamins de 11 ans c'est l'âge moyen c'est
l'âge moyen je sais pas si on l'a dit
dans nos débats là mais cette précision
elle est utile c'est pas à 17 17 ans et
demi voilà c'est 11 ans découvrez
une idée de la sexualité avec des images
qui sont
ultra violentes
n'en expliquées on est loin des cigognes
qui apportent les bébés
etc etc donc voilà il y a pour moi
quelque chose de très délétère et de
dévastateur dans ces images et je
souhaite qu'on traite la question et
qu'on la traite vite en
en travaillant ensemble parce que toutes
les idées sont bonnes à prendre et
pourquoi pas imposer qu'un certain
nombre de choses soient faites par ceux
qui produisent ces films et que l'on
pourrait sanctionner s'ils ne prennent
pas toutes les précautions pour protéger
les mineurs c'est aussi une façon de de
voir les choses
parce qu'il y a là alors je
pardon mais
quand on parle de droit il faut toujours
être précis mais là je le fais pour
vulgariser le propos mais il y a une
forte une sorte de de corruption de
mineur là qui s'opère on n'est pas dans
le texte sur la corruption de mineurs
mais le sens général c'est sain et il
faut pouvoir l'appréhender donc j'ai
j'ai effectivement lancé des travaux sur
cette question et toutes les réflexions
sont les bienvenues parce qu'il faut
qu'on éradique absolument cette
possibilité pour des enfants pour des
petits d'avoir accès à ces images
qu'elle soit violente ou qu'elle soit de
nature pornographique
si vous me permettez juste le temps sur
ce thème là ce matin nous avons eu des
intervenants très intéressants dans le
cadre du colloque que nous avions ce
matin et nous avions l'arcane qui nous a
fait un point de situation d'où ils en
étaient par rapport au décret et des
processus judiciaires en cours et des
discussions qu'ils avaient les
opérateurs nous les avons enregistré ce
colloque on pourra vous donner les notes
et le contenu dès qu'ils ont été
retranscrits excusez moi de vous avoir
coupé allez-y je vous en prie pour
continuer
c'est ça la co-construction
naturellement en étant en lien avec
l'arcom également pour coordonner ce
qu'ils vont faire notamment sur le plan
technique ce que nous allons faire
peut-être la voie pénale en tous les cas
elle est envisagée mais il faut qu'on
règle cette question voilà la réponse
qui est qui est la mienne ensuite j'ai
été interrogé
par Madame Maximy
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que
j'avais tenu à rencontrer Monsieur
Sauvadet
c'est d'abord le département je veux
quand même le rappeler ici
ça n'est pas le ministère de la Justice
même si ministère de la Justice pas
comme vous évidemment est préoccupé par
ces questions et je voudrais vous dire
que le budget 2023 prévoit une
augmentation de plus de 10% des moyens
loués à la pjji 92 agents
supplémentaires ça c'est la réponse que
je peux apporter à cette question
légitime que vous posez il y a le
département et dans la relation
entre le département et l'enfance il y a
le rôle je ne doute pas que vous
l'entendrez peut-être avez-vous envisagé
de Charlotte Cobain évidemment qui est
en permanence en relation avec les
départements pour améliorer la situation
que vous
rappelez et que vous dénoncez à juste
titre
sur les délais de de la justice alors
sur les délais de la justice je voudrais
je voudrais vous rappeler
plusieurs choses d'abord
c'est une de mes préoccupations le temps
long
chaque fois que les Français sont
interrogés sur la justice
il dénonce à lenteur
et de fait ils ont raison
donc on a décidé de réduire les délais
comment on fait pour réduire les délais
il y a plusieurs axes
et plusieurs leviers d'abord simplifier
les procédures
et je présenterai tout prochainement
le résultat de notre travaux
qui concerne les états généraux de la
justice je dis notre travaux parce que
beaucoup de gens ont phosphoré sur ces
états généraux de la justice vous le
savez un comité indépendant présidé par
Jean-Marc Sauvé composé de
parlementaires bien sûr
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
qui était à l'époque présidente de la
commission des lois
François Noël buffet président de la
commission des Lois du Sénat
magistrat de la Cour de cassation
enseignant
avocat ça c'est le comité indépendant
puis un certain nombre de groupes de
travail pour la plupart d'entre eux qui
ont été conduits par de haut magistrats
puis une un travail que j'ai conduit
dans toute la France pour à la rencontre
de nos compatriotes la mise en place
d'une plateforme et de tout cela
il y a un certain nombre de propositions
alors les propositions en matière civile
en particulier parce que je me rapproche
et je vais me rapprocher de façon
précise de la question que vous me posez
nous tous là il résulte que nous irons
je l'ai déjà dit ça ce n'est pas un
scoop vers une équipe autour du
magistrat ce qui permet de rendre des
décisions plus rapides
que
l'équipe autour du magistrat permet
aussi un déstockage et ça nous l'avons
déjà expertisé
ce sont les fameux contractuels que j'ai
envoyé dans toutes les juridictions au
nombre de 2000
aussi villes et 1000 au parquet et les
milles aussi villes ont permis un
déstockage qui est un déstockage
important
on est après de 25% au niveau national
d'affaires au moins déstocker et donc se
déstockage au-delà du terme un peu
techno il est en réalité synonyme de
dossier jugés plus rapidement parce que
moins on a de stocks et plus on juge
vite
évidemment
c'est
développer l'amiable
pour inciter les parties à se mettre
d'accord
et vous verrez que grâce à cela
on va permettre à la justice d'être
rendu beaucoup plus rapidement enfin la
dernière chose bien sûr c'est du
personnel supplémentaire
et
les différents budgets nous ont permis
de mettre cela en place
le budget justice
c'est 44% d'augmentation depuis
l'élection du Président de la République
premier quinquennat
c'est trois fois 8% depuis que je suis
gardé saut ce qui fait 26% parce qu'en
matière budgétaire
trois fois 6 n'ont jamais fait 24
ce n'est pas une incongrie c'est une
réalité et donc grâce à ça naturellement
on a embauché des magistrats dégréfiers
des contractuels comme jamais personne
ne l'avait fait avant nous et
naturellement mais quand on est renforcé
dans une juridiction
ça permet de rendre la justice plus
rapidement et je redis bien sûr que de
ce point de vue tout n'a pas été réglé
puisque nous envisageons une loi de
programmation
que j'aurai l'honneur de vous présenter
sans doute en début d'année prochaine
et il y a
comme l'a dit le président de la
République
un plan massif d'embauche peut nous
allons mettre en place 1500 magistrats
1500 greffiers des contractuels et
naturellement du personnel pénitentiaire
puisque parallèlement à ça vous le savez
nous créons des places de prison
supplémentaires et des CFS naturellement
ce qui nous intéresse plus précisément
aujourd'hui puisque l'on évoque la
question de de l'enfance
quelques réponses que je peux vous
apporter
[Musique]
Erwan Balanant merci d'avoir rappelé
quelques points positifs
c'est rare mais c'est bien et c'est
d'autant mieux que c'est rare
[Musique]
comment faire connaître je l'ai dit un
peu tout à l'heure dans mon discours
notamment la PJJ se déplace
et dit un certain nombre de choses dans
les différents établissements pour
permettre justement aux enfants d'être à
même de connaître
leurs droits
de la même façon
nos envisageons la mise en place avec
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
d'un
passeport éduc droit
justement pour permettre de mieux
connaître nos institutions notamment nos
institutions judiciaires et les règles
de droit c'est pour moi fondamental
parce que dans les deux préoccupations
qui expriment nos compatriotes sur une
plateforme où nous avons un million de
contributions quand même c'est un
exercice démocratique absolument inédit
autrefois quand on voulait réformer la
justice ça se faisait place Vendôme et
que plason dôme donc là on a essayé
d'ouvrir tout cela
et dans ces contributions multiples il y
a deux choses qui reviennent la lenteur
de la justice je l'ai dit un instant
mais aussi le fait qu'elle ne soit pas
suffisamment connue ça cette façon très
large et pour le sujet qui nous
préoccupe aujourd'hui bien sûr Maya le
volet éducatif notamment pour que les
enfants étaient connaissance des droits
qui qui sont les larmes ça me paraît
tout à fait essentiel je pense que le
rapport que l'on a avec les enfants
aujourd'hui est un rapport qui a
beaucoup changé on les considère plus
aujourd'hui comme des sujets passifs
mais comme
des citoyens de demain et donc dans dans
la formation dans l'appréhension de ce
qui est l'importance du droit
de la règle de droit j'ai presque envie
de dire de l'État de droit je suis un
peu optimiste mais ça commence par là
que mettons ensuite demandé alors madame
madame Pasquini
vous m'avez posé un certain nombre de
questions auxquelles je ne peux là aussi
qu'apporter une réponse budgétaire
en regrettant que
vous n'ayez pas voté le budget
ah bah oui mais pardon madame c'est
quand même gentil de vouloir renforcer
les moyens de la justice mais faut être
au rendez-vous du budget quand on le
présente et que justement il permet de
renforcer les moyens de la justice peut
pas avoir le beurre l'argent du beurre
du courtiser la crémière c'est ça n'est
pas possible ça vous voyez au moment où
il faut faire des choix
vous dites NON vous dites non à tout
j'ai dit hier que c'était le mur des
noms
et puis un moment vous dites mais alors
qu'est-ce que comment vous faites mais
mais oui donc nous nous souhaitons
renforcer la justice nous l'avons fait
grâce à un budget que vous n'avez pas
voté pardon de vous alors et vous n'êtes
pas la seule et vous n'êtes pas la seule
voilà
mais qu'est-ce que je dise après vous
râlez parce que les moyens sont pas au
rendez-vous de vos espérances mais quand
on décide les moyens vous n'êtes pas là
pour les voter
c'est en tous les cas ma réponse à qui
n'ai-je pas répondu
normalement je vous avais répondu à
toutes les questions que j'avais noté
pour ce premier tour en tous les cas
j'avais
d'inscrit madame Servane Hugues
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ma question porte sur les
violences sexuelles faites aux enfants
en situation de handicap qui ont trois
fois plus de risques d'en être victime
qu'un enfant valide
160000 enfants sont concernés chaque
année et donc plus de 80% des cas
l'auteur de l'agression est un membre de
la famille cependant les violences que
subissent les enfants en situation de
handicap sont aussi parfois commises par
des professionnels du secteur
médico-social effectivement en contact
très fréquent avec eux
l'inscription au fichier des auteurs
d'infractions sexuels ou violentes en
principe automatique c'est la victime
est mineure peut-être levée par le juge
ou le procureur et la consultation de ce
fichier n'est pas obligatoire avant
l'embauche d'un professionnel au sein
d'une institution en lien avec l'enfance
en pratique la levée de l'inscription au
fichier par les juges et procureur
est-elle fréquente et quelle est votre
position à ce sujet
pensez-vous qu'une consultation
systématique pour le recrutement de
personnels dans le secteur du
médico-social ou plus largement azeux
éducation nationale par exemple serait
une voie pertinente pour réduire les
risques de violence sexuelles commis sur
les enfants par des professionnels je
vous remercie
pour alterner entre majorité et
opposition je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur bernadisse
oui merci Madame la président dans cet
esprit de co-construction qui anime le
garde des sceaux
je proposais non pas que l'on discute
des moyens de la justice qui prête à
polémique puisqu'effectivement on pense
qu'ils sont pas au bon endroit et ce qui
justifient notre notre contre ce budget
de la justice et vous connaissez notre
point de vue le point de notre groupe
notamment sur la construction des places
de prison donc ça nous aura pas échappé
évidemment j'en viens au fond de ce qui
nous occupe sur les social à l'enfance
et l'exécution des mesures ma collègue
Marianne Maximy juste à côté de moi vous
interrogez tout à l'heure non pas sur le
délai de la justice en soi mais sur le
délai d'exécution qui n'appartient pas à
la justice mais bien au département vous
l'avez vous-même rappelé
on peut déjà faire un constat d'échec
vous dites vous avez une collègue au
gouvernement qui est chargé de discuter
avec les départements pour que ça aille
bien bon ça va pas ça va pas et c'est
pas nouveau et ça continue de pas aller
donc déjà c'est peut-être il faut
changer de méthode sur ce sur ce
registre là c'est le premier point
j'aimerais qu'on puisse les auditionner
ces départements défaillants ici dans
cette délégation pour avoir une utilité
politique et concrète ça me semble
pertinent premier point pour mettre la
pression deuxième point vous avez vous
dans vos probiatives une partie de la
solution
je me suis fait expliquer parce que
quand même au début je lui dis mais
qu'est-ce que ça à voir on m'a parlé de
la PJJ j'ai dit mais attendez la PJJ
c'est le pénal
oui c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui il
arrive que des antennes de la PJJ
prennent en charge des mesures civiles
en complément et donc en regard des
textes il n'y a pas besoin de faire de
modification législatives ou
réglementaire même quelconque pour que
la PJJ puisse prendre en charge exécuter
des mesures qui sont aujourd'hui
inexécutées par les départements et ça
c'est de votre prorogative monsieur le
ministre donc je vous pose la question
peut-on envisager que les services de
l'APG vous avez vous-même vanté
l'augmentation de 10% du budget puisse
prendre en charge dans les départements
qui sont défaillants des mesures parce
que à la fin ce qui doit nous animer
c'est l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant et
que la mesure prononcée par un magistrat
soit exécutée pas de se renvoyer la
balle entre département c'est pas moi
c'est l'autre ils sont défaillants mais
oui vous comprenez ma collègue j'ai
envie de dire de manière très triviale
on s'en fout c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est les gosses qu'on doit prendre en
considération
merci Monsieur bernetti et effectivement
nous avons prévu d'auditionner l'ADF
dans les prochaines semaines tout comme
l'AMF d'ailleurs donc nous répondrons à
votre demande à ce niveau-là
Monsieur Philippe fait avait demandé
aussi d'intervenir
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des sceaux dans le cadre de la
protection des enfants victimes de
violence l'autorité parentale peut être
suspendue pour motive grave dès
l'ordonnance de protection au moment du
diverses ou du divorce pardon ou au
si ces décisions de retrait de
permis de parentalité se démocratise
davantage aujourd'hui elle cache
néanmoins une toute autre réalité qui
est celle des rencontres imposées qui
privent ces mêmes victimes de protection
comment peut-on justifier que la justice
puisse par asymétrie imposer des droits
de visite à ces mêmes enfants que l'on
souhaite préserver cette injonction
paradoxale prive les victimes de leurs
droits à la reconstruction et redonne le
contrôle aux parents condamnés sur la
vie des victimes déjà largement est
souvent impactés par un stress
post-traumatique qui brise leur vie
sociale leur vie scolaire et même leur
santé quand le retrait de l'autorité
parentale est motivé ne doit-il pas en
être de même pour les droits des visites
effectivement quand on retire le permis
on ne conduit pas même en conduite
accompagnée merci
merci beaucoup monsieur fait madame
Loire
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux nous avons tous ici
connaissance des problèmes que vivent
des enfants pris en charge par les
services de la zone de nombreuses
scandales ont d'ailleurs récemment
éclaté malheureusement ces problèmes ne
sont pas nouveaux et malgré de nombreux
reportages qui ont été avertis qui ont
averti l'opinion publique ne diminuent
absolument pas aujourd'hui l'accès à ces
établissements est particulièrement
compliqué c'est pour cela que j'aimerais
vous demander ce que vous pensez de
cette impossibilité d'accès au
parlementaire pour cette pour les pour
les centres de protection de l'enfance
et par conséquent si vous sauriez prêt à
vous positionner pour une amélioration
de l'accès à ces centres à nous
parlementaires
merci monsieur
merci beaucoup madame dubrochira
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ma question ne vous étonnera
pas l'enfant qui évolue dans un contexte
de violence intrafamiliale est un enfant
en danger avec des conséquences graves
pour son développement sa santé sa
sécurité qui nécessite un accompagnement
spécifique je voulais attirer votre
attention sur le travail de concertation
qu'on avait fait au mandat précédent et
sur les conséquences liées à
l'exposition de ses enfants dans le
cadre de violence conjugales notre
souhait de placer l'enfant au-dessus du
principe de coparentalité et de
reconnaître l'enfant comme victime de
violences conjugales ce qu'on proposait
c'était la repérage la prise en charge
et le suivi psychologique des enfants
une infraction autonome lorsque l'enfant
est exposé à des violences puisque ça
n'est le il est reconnu comme victime
que dans le cadre pénal et pour aller
dans le sens de mon collègue une
suspension de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale et des droits de visite et
d'hébergement du parent poursuivi vous
condamnés pour violence la réflexion sur
l'exercice d'autorité parentale et
évoluer vous êtes prononcé avec
Charlotte cobel la rentrée pour son
retrait la suspension du droit de visite
et d'hébergement dans le cas limité
d'inceste et de violation sexuelle sur
mineur fin novembre le premier comité
interministériel à l'enfance a acté
cette mesure de retrait et d'éventuelles
suspensions pendant l'enquête nous
proposons de tendre cette suspension de
ce retrait à l'autorité parentale
lorsque les enfants sont exposés dans le
cadre de la délégation nous avons
auditionné la semaine dernière le juge
Édouard Durand qu'au président du
civisme il a rappelé le lien
indispensable entre conjugalité et
parentalité il ne s'explique pas que
l'on ne prévoit pas le retrait juridique
de perpétuer la violence et l'emprise
par l'exercice de l'autorité parentale
ou lors des droits de visite et
d'hébergement il s'est dit favorable de
longue date à une législation impérative
sur les violences conjugales portant
inscription dans le cadre civil et de
cette suspension et de ce retrait
se consensus est largement partagé nous
avons déjà débattu sur ce sujet avec
vous-même et votre cabinet quelle
proposition êtes-vous en mesure de nous
faire dans ce domaine merci
merci beaucoup normalement je n'ai plus
d'inscrire au niveau des groupes je vais
me permettre monsieur le ministre
par rapport à mon propos préliminaire
tout à l'heure vous avez indiqué
qu'effectivement chaque enfant pour
avoir un avocat aujourd'hui on sait que
c'est soumis à la volonté et ou du juge
ou du président de département
j'aimerais donc savoir si vous avez fait
passer des consignes pour généraliser
cette évocat ma question sur la
possibilité d'appel d'une enquête
sociale et sapeur rebondir sur ce que a
dit Monsieur bernalicis c'est-à-dire
est-ce que la PJJ par exemple ne
pourrait pas venir en contre appel pour
permettre le contradictoire qui vous est
si cher c'est qu'aujourd'hui en
procédure de la science éducative le
l'enquête sociale fait foi et il y a pas
possibilité d'avoir une contre-inquiété
je pense qu'il y a vraiment nécessitent
à ce niveau là et enfin sur le tiers
digne de confiance est-ce que vous avez
fait passer une consigne au juge pour
qu'il puisse mieux gérer cette chose là
et sur les retranscriptions d'audition
j' mais je pense qu'effectivement
peut-être que même si on donnait à la
défense la vidéo de l'enfant peut-être
que l'auteur se rendrait compte des des
difficultés de son enfant ou de l'enfant
qu'il a agressé donc voilà c'était les
quelques points sur lesquels vous
m'aviez pas répondu je me permets vu
qu'il y a plus de questions merci
monsieur le ministre
d'abord vous savez bien madame le
Président de chers Perrine que on passe
pas des consignes comme ça au juge quand
on est gardé sauts
mais je vous ai dit que j'en préparais
une
donc vous aurez forcément connaissance
non mais monsieur bernalicis qui est
très soucieux comme moi d'ailleurs de
l'indépendance des magistrats
je ne vous ai pas vu bondir car vous
n'étiez pas attentif sinon vous auriez
fait un bon d'un mètre sur votre chaîne
alors je vais essayer de répondre non
parce qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
questions qui m'ont été posées monsieur
monsieur bernalicis d'abord j'ai plus si
c'est dans l'ordre chronologique mais
peu importe pas grave
tout basculer sur la PJJ c'est pas
possible
à titre exceptionnel la PJJ peut
intervenir
qui a fait d'ailleurs pour les mineurs
autour de jaune
je partage votre constat sur l'existence
de certaines difficultés
mais moi je n'ai pas le pouvoir de
retirer au département d'ailleurs il y a
des départements où ça marche bien dans
les choses oui non on peut douter de
tout en permanence peut-être critique de
tout il y a des choses où ça va bien
d'ailleurs vous-même vous avez fait une
liste des départements dont vous pensez
que ils peuvent être problématiques vous
n'avez pas dit tous les départements bon
parce que ça n'est pas parce que ça
n'est pas vrai mais
on peut travailler sur ce sur ce sujet
d'un transfèrement comment ça se passe
mal
moi je n'y suis pas posé il y a un point
sur lequel je suis en total accord avec
vous monsieur bien dans ici
le but ici de notre réunion c'est pas de
la parole
c'est d'améliorer la situation de
l'enfant mineur bon moi je suis prêt à
tout entendre
et on peut discuter sur toutes ces
questions mais a priori espèce de
transfert qui serait un transfert de
charge insupportable pour la PJJ
d'ailleurs en dépit des efforts
budgétaires que
dont vous n'avez pas voulu
comme ça oui quand même non je dis ça
très gentiment mais c'est vrai en dépit
de ça ce serait quand même quelque chose
de de
un peu simpliste comme vision mais on
peut essayer de travailler sur ces
questions
moi j'ai compris mais alors en fort qui
expertise quand ça va pas bien quel
quoi comment vous comprenez bien que non
mais non mais moi moi
écoutez je suis aux responsabilité et et
donc le Yaka faucon est totalement
interdit
ça c'est un privilège de l'opposition
ces choses dire voilà donc proposition
examen sérieux attentif proposition
sérieuse examen sérieux et attentif on
regarde le but c'est d'améliorer les
choses mais pas n'importe comment et pas
avec un certain nombre de formules un
cantatoires en pas se payer de mots on
essaie de de faire avancer bon faites
moi des propositions j'ai même déjà pris
certains de vos amendements
si chaque fois que vous étiez
raisonnable bon
placement
tout ce qui concerne la famille élargie
d'abord c'est la question du tiers digne
de
ligne de confiance après évaluation des
éducateurs de la zone pour les mineurs
en danger et à défaut ces placements en
institution foyers en famille d'accueil
il y a une évolution notable là qui nous
vient de la loi de février 2022 sur la
protection des enfants
voilà ce que ce que je peux répondre et
quant à l'accès des centres aeux par les
parlementaires
c'est une question que vous devez poser
au département
parce que ce sont eux qui sont
aux manettes vous le savez ça n'est pas
de ma compétence
je crois que Charlotte cobel s'est déjà
exprimé sur cette question me
semble-t-il
mais c'est de la compétence du
Département moi je n'ai rien à dire il
avait été question dans le texte que
j'avais porté que les bâtonniers par
exemple puissent intervenir en prison ce
qui ne leur était pas possible moi j'y
étais
favorable on a discuté voyez comme quoi
on aboutit parfois des solutions qui
sont des solutions devenu pérenne
puisque la loi a été adoptée
bon sur cette question ça n'est pas de
ma compétence pardon je ne fuis pas la
réponse mais la question
n'est pas pour moi
sur
la question d'imposer au juge de
regarder les auditions de la de la
victime
moi j'ai fait état des difficultés
on peut évidemment par voie circulaire
demander au procureur généraux de mettre
en place mais les procureurs généraux
mettent en place auprès des procureurs
pas auprès des judiciaire je sais pas si
on peut à ce stade je suis assez
dubitatif pour ne pas dire circonspect
se passer de support papier
je sais pas
bon maintenant les choses évoluent vous
le savez on fait aujourd'hui de la
visioconférence il était hors de
question d'en faire il y a 15 ou 20 ans
oui il faut qu'on s'adapte aux nouvelles
technologies
voilà la question la question est dans
le débat
bon
parfois d'ailleurs
il y a une retranscription qui suffit en
termes probatoire et on ne va pas
jusqu'à l'enregistrement ça arrive aussi
bon
on regarde je je n'ai pas d'idées précis
sur la question sauf que
c'est peut-être l'ancien avocat qui se
replace en situation si j'ose dire sur
la facilité
bon le procès-verbal c'est quand même
plus simple parfois que
parce que comment vous dire il y a aussi
les repères si vous avez une audition
longue et que vous cherchez un point
particulier vous faites quoi en termes
de de
d'utilisation de cette outil vous
repassez tout
les questions qui se posent elles sont
elles sont si j'ose dire
pratico-pratiques moi j'ai pas de de
réticence principale je me dis comment
on fait avec ce CD qui comporte
l'enregistrement d'un enfant qui peut
durer longtemps
comment on fait
et sur du contradictoire à l'audience
comment on fait tiens vous vous dites
moi je souhaite tel passage mais alors
il est où votre passage puis la défense
dit mais moi je souhaite tel autre et
puis la partie civile des moments j'en
souhaite un troisième voilà ce que je me
dis je veux pas trop comment
pratiquement mais peut-être que
peut-être que ça deviendra possible
qu'en tous les cas il faudrait peut-être
demander moi je me suggère ça demandez à
des magistrats ce qu'ils en pensent
ils vous diront il y a des praticiens
pas des théoriciens
demandaient à des praticiens ce qu'ils
pensent de cette idée moi si on me dit
que pardon
au syndicalistes
vous pouvez toujours demander la vie des
syndicats d'ailleurs je pense que vous
ne vous en privez pas monsieur
bernalicis voilà sur cette question j'ai
déjà commencé interrogé certains juges
et effectivement ils me mettent en
Balance le temps le temps de regarder la
vidéo sauf que pour une heure d'audition
d'un enfant donc une heure passée par un
juge à regarder l'audition c'est 7 à 8
heures de retranscription pour les
forces de l'ordre c'est pour ça qu'à un
moment je pense quand même qu'il faut
qu'on s'interroge entre les deux pour
qu'on ait quelque chose peut-être de
plus simple pour tout le monde mais
après effectivement les juges je me dis
oui mais nous on est habitué au papier
on peut lire en travers etc moi je pense
que diffuser cette vidéo peut aussi
avoir un effet sur le l'auteur de voir
vraiment les dégâts qu'il a pu faire sur
l'enfant plutôt qu'un papier qu'on lui
retranscrit des études informés je pense
que vous avez raison il y a quelques
années la vision n'était pas possible je
pense qu'on en est au prémices mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on regarde dans un
petit coin de notre tête mais regardez
le nombre de secteurs que vous devez
multiplier bon le policier mais cette
heure d'accord mais après l'avocat il va
mettre combien de temps pour
auditionner le et voir les images et
le président et parquet et les
assesseurs
aux assises en particulier vous savez
que maintenant les assesseurs ont accès
au dossier ce qui était pas le cas
autrefois ça fait
7 heures multipliée par bon avoir moins
c'est si on me convain moi je demande
quel convaincu et
ma méthode c'est de consulter et
d'entendre si on me dit que c'est plus
fluide plus simple et qu'en plus on peut
faire gagner du temps à nos forces de
sécurité intérieure
en avant toute je suis pas opposé
d'ailleurs dans les états généraux que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure je voudrais
dire qu'il y a aussi un volet procédure
pénale pour permettre la simplification
justement parce que parce que on a
besoin de simplifier le travail de nos
policiers de nos gendarmes bon
ensuite on m'a posé une question
sur
les violences notamment sexuelles
commissions sur les handicapés
la question au fond du contrôle pjjaze
des différents foyers
plan de contrôle renforcement des
contrôles pour les structures recevant
des mineurs comment on fait pour essayer
d'éviter évidemment des infractions dont
vous dites à juste titre d'ailleurs
quels sont au plus nombreuses en tous
les cas
par définition parce que la proie si
vous me permettez cette formulation et
est une proie plus fragile encore
évidemment bon on pense parfois qu'elle
ne pourra pas exprimer les
sévices qu'elle a qu'elle a vécu bon
alors la PJJ participe vous le savez au
contrôle des établissements et des
services de protection l'enfant
s'appartient des directions
internationales
sont mobilisés pour ces missions de
contrôle en 2022
et en 2023 il y en aura 20 de plus
c'est dire qu'on a pris conscience de la
nécessité de mettre en place et de
renforcer ces contrôles et pour les
professionnels de l'enfance il y a toute
la question des contrôles des
antécédents
notamment du B3 contrôle renforcé depuis
la loi qui a porté on a mis Adrien
taquet la loi de février
contrôle du B2 passage aux figés
systématique avec revoyure tous les ans
bon ce qui permet quand même de
contrôler de mieux de mieux de mieux
filtrer peut-être et au pénal on va le
dire des circonstances aggravantes
qui existent
quand la personne a autorité
l'auteur
ou qu'elle est en charge d'un service
public et
la peine encourue bien sûr et alors
majorée
voilà partie de la réponse
que
aux questions madame la députée que vous
m'avez posée
il y a ensuite la question de
de l'autorité parentale alors
de l'aptitude parentale moi je dis que
cette question est à examinée aussi bien
par le juge aux affaires familiales au
moment d'une séparation par le juge
pénal en cas d'infraction grave
si les sanctions pénales contre les
auteurs de violences faites aux enfants
sont doivent être évidemment réprimés
aucune difficulté là-dessus je souhaite
aussi que le juge pénal statut je vous
l'ai dit de façon systématique sur le
maintien de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale quand c'est un parent qui
mise en cause le juge pénal doit statuer
sur la question d'autorité parentale
sur la question de de la protection de
l'enfant évidemment par son parent et on
prépare un texte pour permettre ça vous
le savez j'en ai déjà fait l'annonce le
retrait de l'autorité parentale de façon
automatique pour les parents qui ont
violé agressé sexuellement leur enfant
ça c'est une des préconisations de la de
la civisme et s'agissant de la
suspension avant qu'on a nation je vous
ai dit mon scepticisme sur la question
pour deux raisons raison raison
constitutionnelle
et raison
de possible instrumentalisation
d'une procédure qui serait détournée de
son objet réel et qui aurait pour objet
de priver d'un des parents de l'autorité
parentale de l'exercice de cette
autorité parentale donc il faut être
prudent là je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
que les les juridictions avaient en
mémoire un certain nombre de dossiers
qui ont été détournés dans leur
finalités qui ont fait l'objet
d'instrumentalisation ça existe il faut
être prudent là-dessus prudent et le
côté automatique est quelque chose qui
me gêne alors je sais que Monsieur
Durand est très allant sur cette
question monsieur Durand il est juges et
il devrait aussi bien sûr ce souvenir
que ces questions là
elles sont essentielles et qu'elles
doivent être tranchées par un juge voilà
ce que ce que ce que ce que je pense
à peu près avoir répondu à tout le monde
je crois que Monsieur Walter voulait
intervenir
oui excusez-moi c'était juste pour avoir
une précision sur ce que vous venez de
dire dans les préconisations du juge
durant il y avait également en cas de
procédure pénale la suspension à la fois
des poursuites pour non présentation
d'enfants pour le parent considéré comme
protecteur et la suspension du droit de
visite et d'hébergement donc vous avez
abordé la question de l'autorité
parentale et je vous en remercie mais je
voulais avoir des précisions sur ce
point-là l'autre question très rapide
que je voulais vous poser c'est que nous
avons parlé lors de cette audition du 6
décembre de l'après civise donc de la
question de comment pérenniser ce lieu
d'écoute et de recueil de témoignages
qui apparaît comme essentiel je voulais
savoir si vous aviez des pistes de ce
point de vue là et juste une dernière
petite question je crois qu'il y a pas
eu de réponse à la question de Madame
Goulet sur la responsabilité des
médecins et donc si vous pouviez nous
apporter des précisions là-dessus
également je vous en remercie
alors il y a plusieurs choses
vous avez raison il y a une question à
laquelle je n'ai pas répondu je vais me
faire un devoir de le faire
d'abord la civisme
son travail n'est pas terminé
je crois que le temps de la mission
c'est 3 ans
bon
alors je sais que un certain nombre ont
été dites
notamment par voie de presse d'ailleurs
immédiatement reprise comme montée avec
tout ce que l'on peut imaginer
comme commentaire autour de de
préconisations
ce travail il a pour objet de nous aider
vous les parlementaires
[Musique]
moi un ministre à orienter à mettre en
place une politique
de meilleure protection de l'enfance
donc il y a un certain nombre de choses
qui ne sont à ce stade que des
préconisations
il faut les entendre comme tel
sur certaines je les dis on est d'accord
au point qu'on prépare un texte
sur d'autres ça mérite une certaine
réflexion moi quand
après réflexion je constate qu'il y a
des difficultés d'ordre constitutionnel
je dis
attention ça mériterait
la civil est un travail important très
important
mais
il faut aussi que l'autorité politique
et sur ce travail
l'autonomie dont nous avons besoin les
uns et les autres nous prendrons
beaucoup de choses de ce que dit la
civisme il y a un certain nombre de
choses sur lesquelles nous sommes
réservés je leur dis le travail n'est
pas terminé donc bel outil et et
merci monsieur Durand de faire ce
travail
nous l'examinerons complètement quand le
travail sera terminé voilà ne
il y a des choses que
dont nous sommes dit ça ça va vraiment
vraiment dans le bon sens et il est
urgent de le mettre en place il y a un
certain nombre d'autres choses sur
lequel il y a des circonscriptions
d'ordre juridiques notamment et sur
lesquels nous devons attendre un peu il
y a un certain nombre de discussions moi
quand je reçois un travail je ne décide
pas tout seul de ce qui est bien pas
bien on discute je suis entouré de
magistrats qui connaissent ces questions
j'ai moi-même une expérience d'avocat on
a recours également au service on
discute d'un certain nombre de choses
voilà c'est comme ça que ça se fait dans
la dans la concertation concertation
utile voilà et donc je redis il y a des
choses qui sont arrêtées je vous ai
parlé d'un projet de texte le reste fait
l'objet encore de discussions et je dis
également parce que c'est vrai que le
travail qui a été accompli par Monsieur
durant et dès à présent un travail dont
on peut dire qu'il est considérable
qu'il est extrêmement
et quand il sera terminé nous en
tirerons les conclusions voilà ce qui
est sûr c'est que ce travail là nous
sera utile
alors sur le les médecins il a
protection des médecins
qui font des signalements aucune
conséquence pénale
c'est une obligation c'est clair
c'est une obligation pour le médecin
de signaler des violences sexuelles sur
mineures on va être très clair donc
le médecin qui dit ce qu'il a constaté
ne peut pas faire l'objet de poursuite
voilà alors il y a parfois des
conséquences on le sait parce que les
familles parfois en veulent au médecin
nous on sait
ce qui retient d'ailleurs certains
praticiens on l'avait aussi ça moi je
l'ai vu dans un certain nombre de
dossiers
médecin de la famille bon ça arrive mais
je pense que de ce point de vue on
assiste à des changements de mentalité
changement de paradigme et aujourd'hui
les médecins ont pleinement conscience
bien sûr de l'impérius nécessité de
dénoncer des faits de violences
sexuelles commises sur des mineurs et
non seulement c'est une impérieuse
nécessité mais c'est une obligation
légale donc voilà et merci de me poser
cette question et je regrette de l'avoir
n'en n'ont pas oublié vous étiez là pour
me rappeler alors mais ça me permet de
redire publ ici un certain nombre de
choses qui doivent être entendus de
façon très très clair
merci beaucoup
je pense que c'est bon merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre pour ses échanges
qui en appelleront d'autres j'en suis
sûr et en tout cas vous trouverez pour
faire avancer tout ce qui est nécessaire
de faire avancer dans le cadre des
droits des enfants mes chers collègues
je voulais vous souhaiter à toutes et
tous de bonnes fêtes de fin d'année nous
nous retrouvons le 18 janvier pour
auditionner la station des mers de
France dans le cadre du futur service
public de la petite enfance vous
recevrez la convocation prochainement
bonne fête à tous merci madame le
Président
joyeux Noël bonne fête de fin de journée